vous êtes bien amusé samedi soir tous
les gars de mon groupe de ragtime sont
morts alors le choix en général je reste
chez moi
this town aux statistiques de sortir
avec vous elle acceptera city et pour ça
je ne demande pas trop timide hop
occupée il avait un parachute
non
pas de parachute
j'ai intégré le shield pour défendre les
populations
cape town pour construire un monde
meilleur il faut parfois détruire
l'ancien et on se fait des ennemis
la communauté du renseignement dans sa
grande majorité ne croient pas son
existence
ceux qui y croient l'on surnommé une
soldate l'hiver il est rapide
puissant
il a un bras en acier
êtes vous prêts il n'ya qu'un pas à
faire
les gens vont mourir
je dois intervenir
on commence quand on vient de commencer
la liberté se paie très cher
et c'est un prix que je suis prêt à
payer
on m'avait dit de ne faire confiance à
personne
voilà le résultat tout est permis
on dirait que c'est vous qui commande et
maintenant capter ces éléments
comment on différencie les gentils des
méchants s'il te tire dessus ce sont des
méchants